we all know that Cam Newton is one of
the best players in NFL history to wear
number one but the only reason he wore
number one in the NFL was because of one
man Jimmy Clawson cam never wanted to
wear number one in the NFL he wanted to
wear his beloved number two Jersey from
his days of playing at Auburn there was
only one issue when he was drafted to
the Carolina Panthers back in 2011
backup QB Jimmy Clawson already owned
that number Jimmy new cam wanted to
switch so he gave him a deal that he
thought he couldn't refuse he offered
him the number in exchange for $1
million cam thought he was joking about
the offer but when he realized Jimmy
wasn't joking cam wasn't having it Jimmy
came back and tried to lower a price of
750k Cam said no again and then made a
promise he promised that no one would
hear of Jimmy Clawson again cam bowled
off for the Panthers won an MVP and
became an NFL icon for a generation of
fans and that really was the last we
heard of Jimmy Clawson